por que uma lata grand bico chega tem um
supermercado são precisos mais de um
milhão decisões e indecisões é uma coisa
que vai acontecer é preciso seguir o
plantar quando não plantar tive fazenda
fabrica tratores e vai fazer uma fábrica
de latas de alumínio é preciso ser
grande é preciso transportar o grão é
preciso em branco e no fim nós temos a
decisão final irão explicar e escolher
uma lata grand ou seja nós estamos
sempre entre os cinco responsáveis pelas
nossas cidades e uma coisa como exemplo
contendo tranqüila a maior parte das
vezes nem estamos com de nós podia
dirigir mais de 10 mil vezes por dia
seria bastante campeonato espectacular
tiro competir é a mulher dele e as
regiões há umas que são muito rápidas
tomadas que é preciso mais com pressão
ao chefe das almas encerradas as nossas
acho que que os outros tomam mais comuns
infantil nós estamos sempre constante é
e a ser influenciados por esportivas
mas quando olhamos para o conjunto das
decisões e essas decisões parecem um
campo em grão é no conjunto interessante
mas qual pode ser o valor de um grama
vou contar uma história é de dois alunos
luiza em 2009 as aulas muito bem
aprendi a 1 sobre o sousa opinião sobre
culturas opinião sobre adaptações
posições mas sentia o desejo de vara e
aplicar esse conhecimento em prática
ainda por cima olhavam para direita e
tinha o recurso que muitas vezes estavam
utilizados muita terra tem os tratores
parados muito conhecimento que estava na
gaveta e não podia ser em prática e
trouxeram nos federal para que a nossa
popular nós vamos fazer algo para nós
pois nós também perdemos mas saímos
daqui com nove pessoas
então tirei isso e tinha um primeiro nós
produzimos aqui alguma coisa é
caracterizar a produção ea resposta foi
lá muito pop porque temos aqui o nosso
lá o sim vai alimentar e hekari precisar
mais de mim
- que vai complementar o banco alimentar
é uma instituição muito grande já está
bem organizada e que colheu foram falar
com outros terão sua idéia
nós temos todo o gosto vai ajudar imenso
noite e vamos apoiar a nossa ideia é
então assim foi teto de produção um time
segurar agora faltava tudo tratar tudo
as coisas aqui no estado
então vou falar com ele e turco as
pessoas responsáveis mas a resposta foi
foi sempre a mesma a isso é uma boa
ideia mas não vai dar
quiçá como funciona uma popular tem
muita burocracia
isso é isso não vai funcionar
excelente idéia é mas isso não é no meu
apartamento em que terá o comportamento
x chegava ao apartamento xx a igreja
muito bem mas não está aqui ter o
apartamento está pronto e e sempre assim
e e as coisas eu e vc já era o próprio
banco alimentar a ligar o diretor ao
explicar a importância que teria o banco
alimentar a criança luiza que teria esse
projeto e convidados poderiam alimentar
mas também para o logos entender que
podem cobrar ele falou olha eu é do
número inicial foi preciso procurar um
firme discurso então as coisas foram
vencermos e os celulares podem usar a
nossa terra e nosso 14
agora temos a terra tem 14 e e agora
quer que te falta
não tínhamos - não tínhamos adubos não
temos nada mas eles não desistiram da
idéia é continuar a investir e as teses
onde tocava a casa optou pelas filhas
ele não se preocupa primeiro ano eu
trago os membros terão transportugal
padrão e nós vencemos no primeiro ano de
campanha e vamos conversar com ele está
feliz
e assim foi chegamos a 2011 é um ano
histórico para o isa para a sua igreja
em 2011 pela primeira vez gump cara
tapada da ajuda pois a entrega é o banco
alimentar isso lida nas com três grandes
o objetivo é aproveitar o recurso juíza
que muitas vezes estava um pouco
utilizados ou mesmo utilizado depois
aplicar o conhecimento
a prática e por fim a alimentar as suas
mais diferenciadas estudo tentando
envolver o máximo a comunidade escolar
professores ele o conhecimento o apoio
técnico e os alunos teriam voluntários
para apanhar implantar e instalar o
sistema de rega e pronto e tudo
funcionou perfeitamente
este projeto não era não era sustentável
não tinha pernas para andar porque não
foi um ano em que o professor trouxe
esse momento porque as coisas não
estavam muito organizadas então faltava
aqui um parceiro fundamental para que
este projeto pudesse avançar foram
empresas de fator de produção sabe
precisamos de empresas viáveis que
vendessem segmentos que vêm sendo que
vender essa em do tipo de coisa se o
branco taffeta asseguram para que este
projeto pudesse ser sustentável 3
continuar ao longo dos anos e se foi é
suas formas quando consegue falar e hoje
em dia já contava com certo ar sites que
figuram como tudo funciona e que tudo
corra da melhor maneira e agora hoje em
dia fazemos sempre dois tipos de
culturas numa área de 45 hectares mas ao
menos cinco fogo e portanto sempre uma
cultura é mecanizada extensiva que ocupa
bastante área mas não envolve a
comunidade escolar como é o caso do
trigo eo câmbio o trigo foi convertida
em 41 bi que é seco o ocorrido e depois
temos também uma cultura intensiva em
uma área pequena mas com mais valor
acrescentado iva e que é preciso muita
mão de obra se espantar a má amanhã a
primeira mão por cada mão as vezes a
arrancar as ervas à mão e tudo isto que
o projeto foi está muito estável e tem
sido sempre que chega de 2011
e hoje em dia já entregamos mais 35 mil
euros mais alimentar ajudando
indiretamente cerca de 80 mil pessoas
através de 175 instituições que vai
implementar apoio mas isto era tudo
muito bonito mas eu não fui convidado
para falar do projeto que outras pessoas
que era preciso alguma me convidaram
para vir aqui falar sobre o que é que eu
tenho participar neste projecto que é
que mudou a minha vida que eu aprendi
com isso conformou e quando fizeram o
convite em 2016 é o convite surgiu de
forma integral porque eu vi o projeto de
um lugar que já tinham vi o que eu
aprendi a ouvir o contato que eu tinha
com as coisas por isso aceitei o convite
uma forma muito natural porque sabia que
ganhar muito muito com isso mas a
partida foi mais tempo bastante coisas
chatas citar muitos dias após apanhar
como escritor
tive que ele chegou é melhor o carro a
casa
tive que passar horas a chegar a cebola
literalmente as coisas foram avançando e
tenho certeza que esse projeto é um
futebol muito como pessoa tirando estas
coisas menos boas
e como é que informou o professor não só
ensinou a parte técnica ea parte de como
evoluir a cultura como nós podemos fazer
para tratar da cultura e como é gostoso
mas também me sentindo é é softwares
como gerir pessoas como comunicar com
empresas como tá no mundo empresarial
tudo isso tenho certeza que vai ser
valorizado morto mas agora esse método
mais opressão e do projeto continuou a
mexer com o tio é deixar seu gado e está
cada vez maior
há pouco tempo recebemos um e-mail da
unidade lotada dizer olhem graças a
vocês nós temos que começar esse projeto
aqui e já está em funcionamento um aluno
que irá buscar do brasil tamanho do
brasil e conseguiu implementar isso não
é verdadeiro e emanuel também maior
graças a vocês agora também já está a
funcionar aqui né
é um inspirado e estamos muito contentes
ainda esta semana eles ligaram de
defender ainda 173 e olhem agora estão a
chegar aos novos alunos e trilhas muito
que vocês viessem carlos clicadas para
tentar mudar o primeiro passo e que isso
possa continuar a crescer
então isto sim é o que cuidava eu queria
dizer continuar no projeto mesmo quando
as coisas não corriam chega a mãe e ver
esse cheiro está sendo muito outros e
que as outras pessoas continuam o caniço
é a nós é muito pouco
ou seja nossas decisões não passam de um
camburão
mas quando lutamos acreditamos que os
times neste verão e escrevam controlar o
mundo nunca olhar
[Aplausos]